we've got a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p you can call
any time of day and here is someone
calling expressing some motherly
sentiment take a listen to this i love
you i would be so proud to be your
mother you are awesome and wonderful
hardworking and i don't i so deeply
appreciate you and i just wanted to tell
you that okay thank you so much right
thank you with peace and love i don't
think we've ever had a caller who
expressed that they would want to be my
mom I think we did once have someone say
they would love to be my grandmother
would you be proud to be this caller's
son I mean I don't know who it is but
she sounds to have a very respectable
political beliefs sounds lovely sounds
lovely yeah alright on today's bonus
show Egypt is now promoting birth
control to fight their problem of rapid
population growth we will also talk
about Fox News getting pulled off the
air in the UK no it's not a free speech
infringement it's just that nobody was
watching Fox News in the UK and it is
now gone and we will also talk about the
FDA marking ecstasy
well MDMA the key the source chemical in
ecstasy as a breakthrough drug for
possible PTSD treatment for former
military service members a lot happening
on today's bonus show david pakman.com
slash membership to sign up and soon
bonus show access coming to patreon at
patreon.com slash david pakman show not
yet but soon very soon folks that you
can believe